on vers une nouvelle interview avec vous
ça s'appelle quand je taperai dans mes
mains tu sors
[Applaudissements]
pendant les géniales voilà voilà où en
est la france on bouge pendant le single
voilà
il est temps que sarkozy mette un peu
d'ordre à tout ça mon âme et oui avec
devedjian oui
bien omar quand je te ferai dans mes
mains tu seras
bien lescure
je mange
quand je taperai dans les mains tu seras
xavier couture
hockey atome a ont un besoin
d'augmentation d'une famille nombreuse à
nourrir
et ça va être effectif dans les
prochains jours
c'est pour vous omar quand je taperai
dans les mains tu sauras jean marie le
pen le soir du premier tour
non me ferais du fémur quoi le pays peut
le faire
jarny si
vous êtes un homme malsain
technocrates vous pressez pas la france
métal ou acculé de dettes
surendettés
hélas
il
bien
quand je taperai dans les mains tu seras
michael jackson
et vingt gamins de présentant à des fins
humanitaires ne
va
pas très bien que la cravate c'est quand
je serai prêt dans les mains tu seras
monsieur riche en beaux de tours
il est décédé ce matin ce n'est pas bien
de se moquer de moi
je vais faire je peux faire madame michu
d'être un peu triste non nous mari meurt
ce matin et cet après midi
à tient au mas quand je taperai dans les
mains tu feras benjamin qu'à celle des
civils et que félicien se bat à mains
nues contre un grizzly tapez 1
par contre si vous voulez que les signes
se fasse prendre par le gaz unique
j'étais à prêt dans le match sera dieu
faire la dune c'est vrai oui trop de
croyance non non pas de trucs sur odieux
le projet a le il a même moore a ses
limites il a peur de dieu oui tu sais
faire le diable les métallos
attention
quand je taperai dans les mains tu seras
fred
limiter les
toits comme je taperai dans le match il
sera au mât
comme ça non c'est à vous la tension
quand je taperai dans mes mains vous
serez thierry ardisson
voir le nouveau thierry ardisson le pote
de guy bedos j'accueille mon ami de
toujours guy bedos
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux